hi there we have just crossed 10000
subscribers on this channel and that is
an absolutely mind-blowing number to
everyone who's subscribed thank you and
today for a bit of a special occasion I
thought we would look at you yes you
handsome one of the 10,000 subscribers
of this channel and we're going to dive
into the YouTube analytics and see who
you are and what you like and how you
behave so if you've never done YouTube
as a creator this is what it looks like
you can see right here there are ten
thousand and seventy one subscribers
right now and if you look at the videos
attention is all you need is the most
popular video on this channel it is also
one of the oldest videos on this channel
probably it's in many university
curricula now and there's like half a
lecture allocated to it and that is not
enough to understand this paper so
people come to this channel I was still
using kind of Adobe Reader at the time
and itching in sort of there's only one
color it's super laggy but for some
reason people like it and I'm not gonna
debate with people about what they like
and what they don't I might do another
one on attention is all you need just
because I understand Transformers much
better nowadays and I think I could do a
better job at explaining them more
clearly so a lot of the NLP models tend
to do very well as videos because I
think people are interested and
practitioners are interested and they
just want to learn about these models
and what they're doing also there's
Siraj controversy very popular it was a
fun event and a sad event this video
right here deconstructing lottery
tickets
it just outperforms all the other videos
absolutely mind-blowing Lee Rockets over
everything but if you look at the
retention
I only retain people for two minutes on
average which is the retention is the
lowest of any of my videos and I could
not understand this for the longest time
and that it occurred to me if you title
a video deconstructing lottery tickets
and you put a bunch of math on the
thumbnail people are gonna click
and then be very very very disappointed
when you don't tell them how to win the
lottery and that takes them about one to
two minutes to notice like oh crap I
can't make any money using this video so
if you go to the general analytics tabs
it's very interesting to see what people
like you see the last 28 days I've
uploaded every single day except here
this is a bit of a gap I have
accidentally deleted the backdrop in the
brain video and had to reapplied it the
next day so if you look at the last year
the views have gone up substantially
these subscribers have gone up but
they're our subscriber spikes
right here and these spikes are usually
sometimes when some large personality
recommends this channel the channel
gains a bunch of subscribers that
doesn't necessarily translate into more
views it's just people that click on
subscribe and then never care anymore
the metric that's most interesting to me
personally is watch time and as you can
see here watch time has gone
substantially up in the last month which
I find to be encouraging one minute of
watch time means that I get to transmit
one minute of information to the viewer
and that's what really matters to me of
course if I'm doing a worse job at
explaining then the viewer has to watch
for longer but that usually doesn't
really work out because they're just
gonna click away all right to the fun
part the audience who are you now as you
can see here 69% of you are not
subscribed what are you doing not being
subscribed though this has changed in
the last month significantly I believe
now it's about half and half what I find
most interesting though is that 10% of
you have this Bell notification on so
10% of you actively want to be disturbed
whenever I upload a video I am
incredibly flattered by this this is the
biggest compliment not even I do this
for the channels that I follow
demographics also very fun about 93% of
you
to be male and about 6% of you tend to
be female at least according to
YouTube's statistics and that's a pretty
good intersection of YouTube being
mostly male and machine learning field
also being mostly male if I'm doing
anything to attract any particular type
of person please let me know so I can
diversify a bit everyone's welcome here
you tend to be above 18 which is good
because we have very very much adult
content on this channel I'm happy to see
that none of you is underage now I think
that's just--that's YouTube just don't
not reporting underage statistics but
most of you tend to be 18 to 45 years
old though to the older viewers you're
of course also very welcome though I'm
pretty sure that some of these is just
because you were underage when you
created your account and you just told
them you were born in 1923 so most of
you tend to come from the United States
or India or Germany this is very
incomplete list I think the most people
simply are in the other category of
countries which I think means YouTube
just doesn't know but it is cool to see
that India is so high up one of the
reasons I started this channel so the
main reason is because it forces myself
to read papers more thoroughly if I have
to explain them one other main reason I
started this channel was because I
thought I thought there was a gap
between what you could get from a
beginners course any sort of Coursera
course and where research is right now
and to bridge that gap you basically
have to go to a very good university and
I know that most of the world doesn't
have access to these very good
universities so my idea was to kind of
bridge that gap to make that person that
has a basic understanding of machine
learning be able to be up to speed with
current research to be able to read
current research papers and the fact
that I have quite a number of people
watching from countries where top
universities maybe aren't located is
very encouraged
to me thanks for watching from all
around the world one person is watching
this with Russian subtitles da okay we
can go into the advanced statistics here
and that is pretty interesting as well
you see here most videos kind of spike
when they come out especially the news
videos they tend to be very popular just
the moment that I release them and then
they sort of fall down traffic source I
find particularly interesting if you
look at the last 90 days there are these
spikes and these spikes tend to come
mainly from from Google searches so at
some point people simply Google search
for stuff and then they find this
channel which is encouraging most people
actually search for attention is all you
need or things like this YouTube doesn't
show you anymore what people search on
Google but YouTube shows you what people
searched for on YouTube and that tends
to be mostly attention is all you need
new 0 my name hello so if you correlate
these spikes in searches with geography
some of these spikes tend to be
worldwide like this one here or this one
here but this particular spike is only
United States and if you look at the
videos that I released during that time
period one of these videos right here so
either it is the shmita bird drama a lot
of people searching for that maybe maybe
it's imagenet v2 or the online
conferences I don't know you can see
right here I didn't make many
subscribers of of these spikes it's
simply people being interested in
content which is pretty cool it is also
interesting to see that these spikes
right here they correspond mainly to
mobile phone users so mobile phone users
go in Google searching for content on
this channel I have no idea what's going
on alright now the last question to
solve is of course monetization how much
money does this channel make and the
answer is
none so far so there are multiple
reasons why I haven't applied for
monetization yet I find YouTube ads just
incredibly annoying especially now that
they've decided to stick to ads in front
of videos I just don't want to bug users
with that if you look at what I gained
from it it's not that much any money
that I would make I would like to sort
of reinvest into the channel and right
now I just don't have any requirements
that might change in the future maybe
once we get to a hundred thousand
subscribers alright that was it for
YouTube analytics of this channel I hope
you are still enjoying this content if
you're not subscribed please do next
update will be at a hundred thousand and
I hope that everything is as enjoyable
as ever thank you for watching thank you
for subscribing thanks for being here
and to the future